bonjour la voie est libre tous les
samedis en direct sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui un invité exceptionnel
françois rebsamen ministre du travail de
l'emploi et du dialogue social bonjour
françois rebsamen bonjour merci nous
accorder un peu de temps dans un agenda
de ministre chez vous vous pouvez
intervenir vous l'avait déjà fait sur
notre site internet sur le réseau
twitter avec le hashtag f3 bourgogne lvl
bourgogne françois rebsamen vous étiez
au premier rang des ministres jeudi pour
la conférence de presse de françois
hollande ça sert à quoi ce genre
d'exercices
à faire la pédagogie et à dire où on est
notre pays en l'occurrence il y avait
tout un volet international parce que ce
n'est pas rien vous l'avez vu la
situation internationale extrêmement
compliqué les dangers sont multiples en
ce moment avec de fortes risques
d'attentats terroristes dans toute la
partie du moyen-orient et donc
l'intervention qui a été décidé par le
président de la république en irak pour
lutter contre dash c'était les égorgeurs
les égorgeurs de ce mouvement terroriste
comment vous l'avez trouvé plus tenaces
ferme je les trouvais souviens quand
vous n'étiez pas ministre vous réclamiez
la pédagogie fermeté est ce que vous
l'avez trouvé comme vous le vouliez
comme on n'était pas ministre j'ai
trouvé pédagogue il est donc ça sert à
ça m'a rassuré parce que il faut dit il
faut dire les choses et le reproche
qu'on peut se faire c'est de ne pas
avoir dit les choses et je sais que ça
s'agace quand audi oui mais dont elle
était en a trouvé la france mais je
pense que les français sont beaucoup
plus lucide qu'on ne le croit il sert
très bien que quand nicolas sarkozy et
partie a été battu l'état dans lequel la
france se trouvait était un état de
faillite c'est à dire françois fillon
l'avait dit lui même déjà cinq ans avant
et donc l'erreur majeure qu'on a fait
c'est de ne pas dire qu' il fallait du
temps pour redresser le pays c'est vrai
il fait du temps et ce temps lien il est
long il est long pour les gens qui qui
souffrent c'est vrai que l'élan pau et
les longs pour les gens qui songent au
mal pour ceux qui trouvent pas de
travail ni les longs et tout le monde
attend la reprise plus l'europe qui
s'enfonce petit à petit dans comment
dire une espèce de de croissance atone
l'anaphore le refrain du jour c'était
c'est difficile alors les supporters en
traduit par c'est difficile mais je me
bats la droite extrême droite ont
répondu on ne pleurniche pas quand on
est président
il est tout sauf pleurnicheurs le
président de la république saïd et
endurant il est dur au mal voilà il en
subit il en prend après tout c'est la
vie démocratique mais on peut pas dire
qu'ils beaucoup de présidents qui était
aussi brocardé par la presse donc ils
endurent il est là il se perd pas ce
qu'il explique c'est que c'est pas
facile de redresser un pays vu l'état
dans lequel les tlc
c'est pas facile dans une europe qui
elle aussi ne fait pas assez
d'investissements c'est pas facile dans
le contexte mondialisé où la vieille
europe est là encore aujourd'hui des
difficultés à aller plus vite pour
investir s'impliquer prendre des
décisions voilà donc moi je les trouvais
pédagogue rappeler où on en était ce
qu'on a fait et oui ça va prendre du
temps je perds le moins de temps
possible mais ça va prendre du temps ça
a pris du temps c'est vrai que ça peut
paraître il a évoqué l'idée du sacrifice
personnel d'une certaine manière est-ce
que ça langage est ce que ça veut dire
que d'ores et déjà compte tenu de ce qui
se passe en ce moment ne sera pas le
candidat à sa propre succession 2017 je
pense que cela ne préoccupe pas pour le
moment qu il préoccupe c'est de d'avoir
des résultats vous savez l'image de lait
français en de françois hollande elle
dépend
quasiment en totalité des résultats que
nous aurons des résultats lé domaine
économique et social et pour le moment
ces résultats ne sont pas là la
croissance elle est nulle comme en
europe le chômage continue d'augmenter
et frappe trois millions quatre cent
mille personnes un peu plus même donc
donc voilà et tu ne seras pas de
résultats les alors après il l'a dit lui
même il a fixé sa ba si le chômage ne
diminue pas
eh bien il n'y a aucune raison qu'ils
soient candidats il le sait donc voilà à
ccc son choix c'est la france et les
français et lui ça viendra après
vous parliez de tous ces chiffres de
tous ces indicateurs on sait aujourd'hui
qu'il ya une impopularité extrêmement
forte autour de françois hollande
il ya les chiffres bien sûr il ya aussi
l'image on entend énormément de choses
comment en est-il arrivé là de votre
point de vue on va dire il faut le dire
aussi bas aussi mal vue d'une très
grande partie de l'opinion aujourd'hui
oui moi je pense que je le redis la la
médiatisation aujourd'hui la société
tels les journaux d'informations 24
oeuvres en continu
un tel impact que personne ne sort
indemne de ce lessivage médiatique
d'autant plus quand on n'a pas les
résultats les résultats je pourrais
prendre l'exemple de j'ai vu ça il y
avait une photo où on brocardait parce
qu'ils ne regardaient pas dans le même
sens que les autres chefs d'état ndlr
en réalité la photo avait été coupé avec
madame merkel il a gardé le même sens et
pour que ce genre de chose près il ya un
terrain il ya quelque chose rires et là
le combat politique s'il faut pas faux
pas de ces pays
là la droite les gens de droite ils sont
sûr toujours pas remis de l'arrivée de
la gauche au pouvoir
que les gens de gauche sont peut-être
les pires ennemis de françois hollande
on a reçu même des tweets depuis le
début depuis qu'on annonce cette
émission de d'autres courants du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui qui sont
extrêmement agressif et on entend des
choses très dures ce françois hollande
venir plutôt du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui à ceux qui font ça dans le
parti socialiste bien il comme il se
tire une balle dans le pied aussi on
mettait les choses comme ça et il tape
contre leur camp ils marquent des buts
contre leur camp c'est c'est c'est pas
bien du tout parce que
apolitique domaine françois hollande il
a très bien expliqué c'est pas la seule
politique possible mais c'est celle
qu'il faut pour redresser le pays
aujourd'hui grade a7 pays et apporter
enfin des résultats aux français on peut
pas tout faire en même temps on peut pas
tout à la fois redistribuer avoir une
politique de l'offre notre appareil
productif il était dans un tel état
désastreux comme tout cela avec si on
avait fait une relance par la
distribution de pouvoir d'achat est bien
l appareil productif il aurait coulé est
ce que vous savez mais je le dis
toujours je crois que le premier
ministre a rappelé c'est moi qui lui ai
donné cette information depuis le
deuxième trimestre 2001 depuis le
deuxième trimestre 2001 il n'y a pas eu
de créations nettes d'emplois dans le
secteur industriel sais pas si on mesure
la dégradation qui vient de se dérouler
en 13 ans de notre pays alors il faut
rétablir notre secteur industriel nous
redonner des marges de la compétitivité
c'est ce qu'on fait avec le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi c'est ce
qu'on fait avec le pack de
responsabilité de solidarité c'est ce
que j'ai fait en réunissant les branches
l'autre jour et en leur disant
maintenant vous avez les moyens il faut
y aller il faut il faut investir il faut
créer de l'emploi il faut faire de
l'apprentissage pour faire de la
formation professionnelle engagez vous
on va y venir justement à tout ça
lamotte ou même avant sur quelqu'un qui
dit du mal du président vous parler
d'industrie aussi vous dresser le
portrait d'arnaud montebourg
est-ce qu'il s'était bien est ce qu'il
fallait dire et arnaud montebourg est-ce
que c'était une erreur de casting arnaud
montebourg à l'économie alors qu'on sait
que les chefs d'entreprise louis noël à
ses farouches non je crois que là il a
passé une la première année à les
secouer auraient des choses comme ça
avec son talent une du talent arnaud et
puis la deuxième année à les câliner et
finalement je pense que il avait trouvé
vis-à-vis des chefs d'entreprise le
bouton il aime l'industrie il est un
département industriel la saône-et-loire
et quand on parlait au petit membre du
medef départementaux des êtres une image
très négative d'armes au monde oui mais
je pense que au niveau national les
responsables nationaux avaient râlé les
grands patrons on va dire que ce soit le
patron de du secteur industriel de
l'automobile psa etc il a bien vu qu'il
avait bien vu qu'il était attaché à la
défense de l'industrie française elle
allait trop loin là il est allé trop
loin mais celui-ci après c'est un
problème de comportement quand on est
ministre de la république on doit être
respectueux de la fonction je vais pas
être vexant mais c'est une c'est un
comportement de gamin s'est fait
gamineries on va pas comme ça une fête
de la rose comme tous les ans puis aminé
de l'éducation une semaine avant la
rentrée enfin franchement voilà c'est
cette génération il faut que elle se
comporte mieux sur le fond j'avais rien
à reprocher mais on peut pas ce qu'on
peut pas comme ça plaisante et la
situation n'amène pas la plaisanterie
points dans cette génération mais aussi
un peu plus jeunes même thomas thévenoud
ben bourguignon j'espère que c'est une c
ça restera une brebis galeuse veux dire
par là que je vais pas assimiler toute
une génération à thomas thévenoud c'est
incompréhensible invraisemblable je me
suis toujours méfié des chevaliers
blancs de ceux qui donnent des leçons à
tout le monde
roger raison d'envoyer vous êtes pro
vigne ont comme lui vous risquez de le
croiser dans le tgv vous le dirais quoi
si vous croisez je lui dirai bonjour tu
dois démissionner de l'assemblée
nationale qu'est ce qui va le faire
c'est sa responsabilité c'est pas la
mienne dans les mauvais coups de la
rentrée il ya eu aussi le livre de
valérie trierweiler il se dit que
ségolène royal avait organisé la veille
de la sortie d'une réunion avec des
fidèles à laquelle vous étiez c'est vrai
puisque ça c'est dit oui
c'était quoi l'idée amortir le choc non
du 17 il y a des amis il a des amis
présents à un public voilà il peut voir
ses amis tranquillement un soir là sans
que ça fasse la une de la presse y avait
des choses très dures contre 110 dans ce
livre vous qui connaissez je ne vais pas
lui donc vous avez lu les meilleures
feuilles dans la presse que ce n'est pas
lui j'ai en tendant la main ce qui se
disait je n'ai pas lu je ne le lirai pas
ça correspond pas du tout c'est ça le
sens de la vie peu sens de ma question
savez vous ce qu'est ce que j'ai vu dans
la presse m'a révolté révulsés c'est
exactement le contraire de françois
hollande que j'ai vu que j'ai côtoyés
lequel j'ai travaillé pendant 12 ans ça
me permet de le dire ici si jamais un
jour françois hollande avait eu un
comportement comme celui que j'ai vu
dans les bonnes feuilles ou si jamais il
avait employé une expression comme celle
là qui étaient employés mais je ne
serais même pas rester une seconde de
plus avec lui jamais j'aurais travaillé
avec quelqu'un qui voudrait dire ça mais
c'est tout le contraire de notre combat
je dis bien de notre histoire c'est pour
ça que je prends ça vraiment pour une
excuse et moi que c'est vraiment un
comportement dégueulasse
vous travaillez avec manuel valls
il a dû affronter
demandé un deuxième vote de confiance
est-ce que ça se passe bien avec le
personnage
on a beaucoup dit pendant la campagne
présidentielle vous étiez un petit peu
en concurrence pour le ministère de
l'intérieur à l'époque à cet élu ça a
été désappointé - saint-élie c'est comme
ça comme ça la vie moi j'avais d'autres
satisfactions est tellement grande ici
dans cette ville dans cette
agglomération c'est la bonne personne à
la bonne place manuel valls aujourd'hui
il y là je crois de qualité majeure en
ce moment il est
dynamique bon ça d'autres personnes
peuvent l'être mais il est courageux il
est courageux et il est volontaire et
donc lille a la volonté de porter
c'est pas facile non pour lui non plus
pour nous en ce moment mais là la
volonté de porter les engagements du
président parce qu'on est sûr que cette
politique elle va réussi à lever marcher
alors justement vous êtes muni du
travail françois rebsamen vu les
chiffres vous êtes plutôt ministre du
chômage
la courbe ne s'inverse pas françois
hollande avait dit qu'elle s'inverserait
alors on s'est trompé on lui a menti
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous savez il
ya 2 il ya deux choses un peu
différentes aujourd'hui ça me permet en
quelques secondes de rétablir un peu la
vérité la courbe du chômage c'est la
courbe des inscrits à pôle emploi tous
les mois
ceux qui s'inscrivent pour l'emploi tous
les mois et puis il ya le chiffre
officiel du taux de chômage le taux de
chômage dans le pays en france
métropolitaine je dis bien en france
métropolitaine ont comparé aux autres
pays européens il est de 9 7% c'est
énorme mais il a déjà été pire en france
il a déjà passé le disque qui s'est mis
donc on a il n'a pas augmenté en allant
il n'a pas augmenté en un an il était de
9 7% en juin 2013 il est de 9 7% en juin
2014 ça c'est le taux de chômage
internationale c'est la comparaison
internationale
mais on a l'impression que les
commentateurs ils veulent pas s'y
arrêter ils veulent pas s'arrêter à ça
pourquoi c'est pas de la faute des
commentateurs c'est parce que on a
focalisé mon prédécesseur il a focalisé
parce qu'il pensait que ça allait
marcher sur le chiffre mensuel des
inscriptions à pôle emploi moi j'ai
sorti ça parce que je pense que c'est
pas c'est pas un bon référentiel je
préfère donner un peu de temps pour
porter jugement voilà bien sûr je
regarde les chiffres des inscriptions à
pôle emploi comme tout le monde fasse
émerger de les commenter tous les mois
pour vous
mais au bout de deux ans et demi non
seulement il également non seulement il
n'a pas baissé il a augmenté ils avaient
augmenté de 800 milles sous nicolas
sarkozy on en est à 450 milles de plus
c'est insupportable et vous avez chanté
les chômeurs qu'en soirée de semaine en
demandant des contrôles alors c'était
quoi c'était volontaire il y avait un
but où c'était un mot qui a dépassé un
peu votre pensée non parce que je vais
bientôt les
bien pensants c'est sûr ça dans vos
rangs parti socialiste ce qui est clair
du parti socialiste c'qui bien connu
pour le travail qu'il a fait mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que vous savez vous
allez vous allez dans les milieux
populaires ils comprennent ça moi j'ai
pas voulu stigmatiser les chômeurs de ma
vie est ce que je me suis battu ici tous
les jours et d des entreprises en
difficulté pourrait aider ceux qui
allaient être au chômage donc j'ai
absolument pas voulu je profite pour
stigmatiser les chômeurs mais c'est
quand même un drôle de pays où quand on
dit les droits et les devoirs on se fait
brocarder les droits c'est quoi c'est
tout ce qu'on sait pour les chômeurs on
a raison de le faire c'est tout ce qu'on
met en place toutes les politiques d des
contrats aidés
peut-être c'est parce que six ans
d'ailleurs l'accompagnement pour
retrouver un emploi dans des moments
difficiles et puis le devoir c'est quoi
quand on est chômeur on cherche on
cherche un emploi c'est d'ailleurs la
définition ces demandeurs d'emploi donc
ça veut dire que cherche un emploi j'ai
rappelé à et j'ai dit qu'il fallait qui
est des contrôles les contrôler ils
servent à quoi ils servent à voir
pourquoi les gens abandonnent pour
certains la recherche d'emploi sûrement
parce qu'il peut y avoir des causes de
maladie peut y avoir une certaine
attitude fait qu'on réponde pas aux
offres aux démentis fond et quand on dit
il faut contrôler plus et mieux cesser
le travail de pôle emploi on prend
armand c'est la curée médiatique
des bien pensants
droits et devoirs je les rappelle ici
c'est la république c'est la république
les droits et les devoirs ce qui est
insupportable c'est de voir comme ça
transformer les propos bon on va dire
que ils ne connaissent pas ce qu'ils
disent savoir est-ce que ça s'appuie pas
aussi sur un contexte en ce moment qui
est que françois hollande a lancé un
certain nombre de réformes il a
énormément parlé du rapport avec les
entreprises et il ya aujourd'hui un vrai
conflit de fonds à l'intérieur même du
parti socialiste entre on va dire les
gens comme vous qui veulent agir sur le
marché du travail et qui parle aux
entreprises et puis et est ce qui vous
est arrivé avec avec les chômeurs est ce
que ça rentre pas dans ce contexte là en
gros il ya une partie des ministres
aujourd'hui qui sont vus par une autre
partie de la gauche comme des gens qui
sont en train de trahir leur parti oui
mais je suis
on peut le dire comme ça est ce que vous
leur santé comme ça t'es pas trahir mais
le mot est fort mais en tous les cas ne
pas être conforme à ce que à l'idée
qu'ils se font d'une certaine gauche ça
c'est vrai mais c'est une petite partie
c'est ce qu'on appelle les frondeurs
c'est une petite partie ya quand même
deux cent soixante dix députés ont voté
la confiance l'autre jour et les autres
se sont abstenus
mais ceux qui se sont abstenus considère
que l'entreprise est le lieu du conflit
et du combat de classe moi je considère
qu'en économie on doit être pragmatique
je l'éprouvé à dijon je pense que en
économie faut être pragmatique l'autre
prise celle c'est là où se créent la
richesse de ce pays c'est pas le patron
c'est les salariés de l'entreprise mais
il faut que ceux qui sont comme ça
vienne voir ce que c'est la vie d'une
entreprise faut voir comment les
salariés sont attachées à la vie de leur
entreprise comment pour certains c'est
un véritable crève coeur quand
l'entreprise est elle pose les armes
c'est-à-dire à l'est est la mise en
liquidation c'est pour certains c'est
leur vie ils font pas de l'idéologie ils
veulent que l'entreprise elle fonctionne
le mieux possible qu'ils soient mieux
payés possible nous aussi qu'il y ait
des droits sociaux qu'ils soient
respectés mais en fait la richesse et
les produite par les salariés des
entreprises et donc la pragmatisme pas
de dogmatisme moi je refuse de
dogmatisme en matière économique ça doit
être ça la vraie différence alors il ya
ceux qui considèrent que c'est le lieu
de l'affrontement que tous les patrons
sont à prendre par les pieds je ne le
pense pas c'est tout et en même temps il
ya toutes parts de réforme en direction
des entreprises avec le pacte de
responsabilité avec un certain nombre de
chantiers qui s'ouvrent aussi vous fait
un pas vers les chefs d'entreprise on a
la sensation que les entreprises font
pas forcément un pas vers vous en ce
moment pas tous mais je laisse coup ce
qu'ils ne font pas permet aussi de le
dire je vais vous les avez réuni sur le
pack de responsables gérer l'île aux
ourlets les 50 branches les plus
importantes que ça représente 11
millions et demi de salariés d'ailleurs
j'en profite pour dire quatre autres
branches en france des branches c'est je
le dis pour être spectateur ils
comprennent pas toutes choses que c'est
une branche à un dire eh bien les
brancher tout un secteur de l'économie
dans lequel il y à des entreprises les
entreprises d'un même secteur de
l'économie et donc sur ces 50 branches
professionnelles il y en a 1 33 qui ont
commencé des négociations je rappelle
que le contrat le pack de responsabilité
était votée le 23 juillet bon alors mois
d'août sauf qu'il a été annoncé en
janvier oui mais les gens pour leur dire
on va faire ça ça va créer des enfants
c'est vrai mais ça c'est le décalage
entre du temps politique entre l'effet
d'annoncé le vote au parlement et puis
après il ya le temps la négociation
française est ce que le système français
de cette négociations par branches et
démocrates syndicale il est encore il
aurait dit non aux besoins de l'économie
et des gens aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il est
encore pertinent il est pertinent parce
que quand s'est passé quand un accord
est passé par le dialogue social cirque
il a été validé par les partenaires
sociaux il est beaucoup plus fort et
quand ça on prend l'exemple des
intermittents c'est pas le cas mais
parce que il y a aujourd'hui une
nouvelle négociation qui est ouverte
mais je
vous en parlais des intermittents ou
même de leur temps de crise on fêtait la
pertinence de ces grands accords de
branche les centrales oui je prends
l'exemple de des industries chimiques
ses 47 1500 emplois qui vont être créés
dans les trois ans c'est 5000 apprentis
qui vont être embauchés alors évidemment
la cgt dit oui mais c'était prévu non
c'était pas prévu c'est 40 de miliana
47500 ses 5000 emplois de plus qu'ils
vont être créés dans les trois ans c'est
un accord de branche c'est très
important cet accord il est validé par
la cfdt par d autres organisations
syndicales moi je regrette que la cgt au
niveau national ne vote pas d accord que
la cgt au niveau local du très bon
syndicaliste très fin très actif qui est
de leur entreprise dans les entreprises
qui se battent pour le c'est pas pareil
des fois au niveau national au niveau
local les branches on va y arriver et on
va réussir sur le chômage j'en suis sûr
ça le cic le retour de compétitivité aux
entreprises et je le dis aux entreprises
je sais que il faut investir les
entreprises elles doivent à réinvestir
le cicr va en voir avec le premier
ministre on va voir le crédit d'impôt à
quoi il sert dans les entreprises où 20
des entreprises elles ont acheté des
machines outils elles ont employé at on
fait de l'emploi j'espère que ça va se
traduire un moment un décalage entre les
entreprises dans la vie quotidienne et
le medef de la même façon que vous
évoquez ce décalage entre les
syndicalistes locaux et les branches
nationales les confédérations si je le
dit trop j'aurais du mal à continuer
votre maman fonction sert de négocier
avec les mais je crois qu'il y a une il
faudrait que dans l'interprofessionnelle
c'est à dire dans les grandes
représentations au niveau national lemon
posture il ya moins une posture et qu'il
s'inspire un peu plus les uns les autres
de leur efficacité dans les entreprises
et dans les syndicats locales dans les
boîtes à outils pour essayer de créer de
l'emploi on a parlé du pacte de
responsabilité vous parlez du cicr il ya
eu aussi un certain nombre de chantiers
lancés le medef a fait des propositions
il ya des choses qui sont sur les rails
un petit mot juste sur l'apprentissage
puisque ya eu une opération
l'apprentissage la baisse des apprentis
actuellement elle était liée à la
suppression d'une aide aussi au début du
gouvernement héros on a justement c'est
même une erreur toute façon c'était une
erreur d'avoir modifié ça mais on à
analyser plus finement les choses hier
avec celle d'entreprises d'ailleurs qui
étaient là toutes les branches étaient
représentés les organisations syndicales
ces huit heures de travailleurs sur ce
sujet ces multi causale mais c'était une
erreur parce que ça a été un impact
psychologique ça eu un impact plus
psychologique que financier voilà donc
serré on a mis dans une lettre oui je
pense était une erreur quelque chose que
du nord alors on a rétabli hier on à
rétablir la double est donc maintenant
enfin on va faire lancer une grande
campagne pour l'apprentissage les
entreprises vont y aller hier avant-hier
avec luc oursel le patron d'areva
annoncée 2000 alternant dans son
entreprise tout ça va va payer un moment
les entreprises commencent à comprendre
qu'elles ne peuvent pas faire le pari de
refus de l'apprentissage et c'est donc
en plus on va les aider maintenant
puisqu'on a mis en place cette prime de
2000 euros on continue pour les onze
d'entre eux ont continué à ouvrir la
boîte à outils
les seuils sociaux françois rebsamen est
ce que vraiment supprimer les seuils
sociaux les modifier ça rapporterait des
emplois on entend tout et son contraire
c'est vrai il faut vraiment aimer pour
la plus de temps pour expliquer les
choses ce que je souhaite c'est que on
passe dans notre pays c'est très
difficile d'un affichage c'est-à-dire de
droit qui sont affichés et aux droits
réels j'ai donné un exemple simple vous
savez il doit y avoir un délégué du
personnel dans les entreprises de plus
de 10
66% des entreprises de entre 10 et 20
ans n'ont pas de délégué du personnel
parce que oui parce que peut-être on
trouve pas parce que et ça c'est des
fois je dis aux organisations syndicales
c'est pas normal c'est pas normal voyez
vous nous satisfaisait de ça mais moi je
m'en satisfais pas et donc il faut que
nous nous inventions
oui je voudrais que vous savez il ya
beaucoup de niaque et lourdeurs dans les
seuils le seuil de 50 il est d'une
lourdeur absolue et donc on peut
simplifier et en même temps on peut
améliorer la représentation il s'agit
pas de supprimer les la représentation
du personnel au total de l'améliorer
c'est ce que j'ai demandé mais par
contre il ya des réunions qui sont
multiples et même les syndicalistes le
reconnaissent donc j'espère qu'ils vont
aboutir à l'iss et à avancer à
simplifier ses seuls et puis il ya des
choses sur lesquelles on est un danger
non bougera pas moi je les dis j'ai
repris le medef là dessus la durée
légale du travail de 35 heures c'est
autour de ça qu'on peut négocier il ya
des possibilités de l'image ça a été un
succès le smic on va pas en plus avoir
une trappe à bas salaires tirés vers le
bas il ya encore trop de branches qui
n'ont même pas encore le smic donc
il faut il faut aller plus haut plus
vite par contre il ya des ouvertures
qu'on peut faire c'est le cas de le dire
maintenant c'est le travail du dimanche
et trois minutes avant midi c'est bien
que c'est court mais le travail du
dimanche oui on va avancer je vais jouer
lens et je vais
forme de schizophrénie dans le pays
autour du travail du dimanche quand on
ouvre un centre commercial de dimanche
en général il ya du monde dedans et puis
en même temps les syndicats disent il
faut pas le faire ça créera pas
d'emplois mais qui de votre point de vue
que les red bull je vais essayer de dire
les choses de manière très simple le
repos dominical
c'est le principe l'ouverture c'est
l'exception et il y a en france des
zones d'intérêt national
touristique ces zones nationales
d'intérêt touristique elle devrait
pouvoir est ouverte le dimanche mais il
faut des accords entre les partenaires
sociaux il faut des compensations
salariales et il faut que ça se fasse
sur la base du volontariat est ce que
c'est normal que les champs-elysées soit
fermée le dimanche alors que les
touristes se promènent et que sinon ils
vont faire leurs courses à rome à
londres ou parce que c'est comme ça que
ça se passe aujourd'hui est ce que ça
commençait à dijon les magasins soient
ouverts le dimanche dans le débat non ma
dimanche à du jour à dijon ou dans les
métropoles régionales
aujourd'hui on peut ouvrir jusqu'à cinq
dimanches par an donc le rapport ben ali
qui sera mon
livre de base le rapport bailly qui a
été fait et qui rencontraient
l'assentiment des partenaires sociaux
est proposée jusqu'à 12 dimanche on va
voir ce que les parlementaires en 10
mois je trouve que douce et un peu
beaucoup sur les 200 euros nets
il se serait encore mieux si ça se
faisait comme à dijon sur la base d'un
accord entre partenaires sociaux
ordonnance ou pas ordonnance sur le
travail du dimanche les ordonnances on
explique c'est beaucoup plus facile
qu'un débat au parlement sur un vide
pour leurs goûts avec des bouées parce
que le problème c'est le temps ça aussi
il faudrait expliquer aux français un
jour surprenant puisque j'ai été
président d'un groupe parlementaire donc
je peux en parler le temps parlementaire
est beaucoup plus long que le temps
économique malheureusement où vous
l'avez dit pour le pack de
responsabilité annoncé fin janvier par
le président voté fin juillet donc non
je pense qu'on aura le débat il n'y aura
pas de je crois pas qu'on passera par
ordonnance il faut savoir pas plus
sachant que c'est aussi un débat de
société travaille dans les rangs
merci françois rebsamen déjà pour cette
demi heure passée à notre compagnie et
on va se retrouver juste après des
informations de midi on parlera bien sûr
du retour de nicolas sarkozy forcément
parleurs un petit peu ce pour une
surprise c'est une surprise voilà c'est
un début de réponse on parlera un petit
peu dijon aussi donc conseiller
municipal maintenant on dirait un petit
mot sur le livre dont on pensait que
vous viendriez avec vous aujourd'hui ce
livre qui n'est pas encore sorti voilà
ce sera dans une poignée minutes après
les informations de midi avec elle a
besoin tout de suite à tout à l'heure
pour la deuxième partie de la voie est
libre
il est midi bonjour à tous
l'installation d'un poulailler